when Spain's Supreme Court found nine
Catalan separatist leaders guilty of
sedition in the pursuit of independence
shock quickly turned to anger the
streets of Barcelona was set alight in a
series of late-night confrontations with
police and the question of Catalan
independence came to dominate yet
another election campaign Spain's fourth
in four years it's a very difficult
moment and in the end I can only speak
for myself not for others because people
have reacted in different ways Lara Maas
vidal's husband Joaquim was Catalonia's
interior minister when the region held
its illegal referendum on independence
in 2017 he was given a nine-year jail
sentence I think this ends any hope of
reconciliation and also any confidence
that people had to find a political
solution
there was a time for that but I think
it's over now the clamor for
independence that divides a country also
divides Catalans a greater proportion of
whom according to the polls don't
support the cause like business owner
Juan River Julia societies in in order
to grow to develop they need stability
stability is the main ground for
confidence when there is confidence the
companies invest consumers spend money
so everything is on hold
everything is at this moment in stable
so at this moment we are we can say that
we are society on hold it looks as if
once again a divided Catalonia will not
find comfort in the ballot box it's true
that the secessionist question is the
big issue in this election but that's
mainly because the big parties are
competing against one another over who
takes the hardest line against Catalan
independence the Catalan independence
issue has captured all this attention at
the national level because it posed like
a challenge to the status quo in the
stability of the of the state and it's a
challenge that nobody seems to have any
answer
no not so far I would say so my
impression is that this is going to be
in a sort of like a stalemate situation
for a few years the polls predict no
majority winner socialist leader Pedro
Sanchez is expected to score highest and
will likely try again to form a
coalition but no scenario offers hope to
the separatist cause in Catalonia so the
scenes that followed the sentencing of
its leaders in October may turn out to
be among the last desperate throes of a
movement with nowhere left to turn
Jonah hull al-jazeera Barcelona